hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food
and make it fancy but first some
exciting news
we've got new merch as i like to say
anything round is cute you can find it
at
shopmakeyfanzi.com now
let's see what we are making fancy today
drum rolls
nothing what's going on here check your
phone you might have just received a
special message
it's eugene hi rea it's me eugene
and my pup kim bob as you may know many
of our viewers have noticed that we have
something very
special in common and no it's not that
we're both amazing
it's that whenever we cook we have been
known to add maybe a
tiny empty bit of alcohol because we
have excellent taste
so naturally i am a big fan of what you
do
but there is one thing that you haven't
made fancy yet
that i'm dying to see i used to love
pop-tarts as a kid and
now as an adult i don't know there's
just something
missing so i have a challenge for you i
dare you
to make pop-tarts fancy i know you'll
come up with something amazing and i
trust that there will be some nice adult
flavor
good luck riya and i'll see you at the
end of the show to check out the results
and of course do the dance with you make
it beauty
make it bougie and make it boozy oh my
god that's your catchphrase right
i made my puppy fancy
all right challenge accepted eugene
pop tarts as you can guess
i've never tried this before i
can guess it's like a
pastry with jam inside i like
strudel for kids frosted strawberry
it's a nice cute name pop tarts
oh wow i'm gonna break it no
snaps it's kind of soft yeah
it's not bad i think i would prefer
toasted crust
is a little bit still doughy jam is nice
it's a little bit
not too sweet i was afraid it has jam
and frosting it could be too sweet but
the frosting is kind of subtle
the sweetness caught up it's very sweet
now
there is a delay i'm getting like
sugar rash
it's still challenging because it's a
complete meal i
not sure how i can be constructed
eugene chose a tough ingredient but i
have a crazy idea
that i think yuji would like spoiler
there will be alcohol
so as always i'm excited to make it
fancy
all right here's what i got white
chocolate gelatin
milk gelatin powder heavy cream eggs
mascarpone cheese condensed milk lemon
and strawberries from the pantry i got
vanilla extract food coloring almond
extract
sugar cake flour salt and
for eugene rum okay let's get started
make it fancy
i'm gonna start working with pop tarts
when i taste it
it was a little bit doughy when you bake
it it's easier to split
and kind of deconstruct easier as well
so i'm going to bake this at 400 degrees
about five to six minutes
until golden brown okay it's nice and
toasty
basically i want to separate jam
and crust i am trying to
scrape the top part so i can get as much
jam as possible it's kind of
innards of pop-tart it's like a blood
i'm scraping
jam from the crust as much as possible
put it in a little container
okay so i'm going to set this aside for
later and i'm going to use this jump for
the next step one pound of strawberries
chopped one and half teaspoon of lemon
juice
two tablespoons of sugar and the
jam i scraped from the pop-tarts
cook this over low simmer about five to
ten minutes
stir occasionally so it doesn't burn on
the bottom strawberries
looks very soft transform to the blender
puree until smooth
so this is looking good and ready to
move on one and a half teaspoon of
powdered gelatin
add two tablespoons of water to blue
and it takes about five minutes
meanwhile use
half cup of puree i just made
one and half teaspoon of lemon juice
two tablespoons of sugar mix it up
adding back bloom the gelatin simmer
until gelatin
has dissolved strain with mesh seams in
case
if there is a big chunk of gelatin it
didn't dissolve
also kind of strain strawberry seeds
right looking good pour into
this fancy mold so if you don't have
this
kind of mold you can just pour
into a baking see and you can cut
with cookie cutter okay so i'm going to
chill this in a refrigerator about three
to four hours until set
pop-tart shell that i saved from earlier
put in a food processor pop-tart jam
kind of look like a blood and look like
a murder thing
so i muttered pop-tart puffs
want to process until like fine
this looks good transfer into a bowl
and we are going to use this for next
step i have
two eggs separate egg yolk and
egg whites add two tablespoons of sugar
into egg yolk and whip it will take a
little while
what you're looking for is pale yellow
color
and consistency of like mayonnaise
all right it looks good adding 1
tablespoon of milk
and half teaspoon of almond extract
and whisk until well combined
sift six tablespoons of
cake flour adding two tablespoons of
pop-tarts flour switch to spatula
because
once you add the flour you don't want to
create a lot of gluten combine well
until you won't see any flow of it guess
when popcorn came out
1965. 1963.
wow so close butter looks good
i'm gonna set this aside and move on to
the next step
two egg whites two tablespoons
of sugar whip what you're looking for is
like egg whites get glossy
and in between hard pick and soft peak
and here is what it should look like
combine
whipped egg whites i'm gonna just add
like one scoop and loosen the butter
the butter is getting fluffier my
favorite
try guy video is when using ranks
like popular food and also he ranked the
astrology sign
and he said scorpio it's the best sign
and i'm scorpio scorpio is very loyal
and a little bit savage pour this on
greased parchment lined baking
sheets and spread this
evenly it's kind of pretty color it's
almost look like a birthday cake
because frosting had a sprinkle on it we
are going to bake this at 350 degree
about 9-11 minutes
until edge is golden brown right cake
came out very nice i want to infuse
rum while cake is hot i'm adding some
adult flavor
oh nice i like smell of rum
and use the pastry brush just soak
for baking i like to use brandy
or rum it's kind of compliment
dessert and of course if you don't want
to
use alcohol you can totally skip this
part
but to kind of give a nice moisture to
the cake
you want to substitute with simple syrup
which is
equal parts of sugar equal parts of
water
bring it to a boil until sugar dissolves
and you can just soak in the same way
using pastry brush
i think this is enough alcohol for now
looking good let's move on to the next
step i have
remaining pop-tarts from earlier warm up
one cup of heavy cream just rough chop
pop-tarts put them in a heavy cream
simmer this and infuse pop tarts
because when cream is hot it infuses
flavor better
new year february
[Music]
working on it i just can't find a time
to practice or get on the highway
maybe i'm gonna do it on the way to
coming to shoot
make you fancy next time and if i don't
show up what do you do
i'm always preparing for the worst case
scenario
it's part of being scorpio too right so
it's
simmered i am going to infuse
off the heat about 30 minutes 30 minutes
later so pop tarts infused
in a heavy cream and i'm going to strain
press
gently okay i'm going to chill this in a
refrigerator
about 30 minutes until cold so i have
three sheets of gelatin and a cut in
half
and you want to broom it in a cold water
and make sure this is a cold water if
it's warm
it's gonna melt soften this about three
to five minutes
and i have half cup of strawberry puree
with pop tart jam
i'm gonna heat it up my she gelatin
is softened and you can easily kind of
like grab it
and pop in and make sure this
dissolves completely take this off from
the heat
set aside and move on quarter cup of
mascarpone cheese
quarter cup of sugar combined with stem
adding half teaspoon of vanilla extract
half teaspoon of almond extract
and whip well add strawberry puree with
gelatin
i just made mix it up make sure
everything is like dissolved
and combined while looking good whip
pop tart infused heavy cream
until stiff peak nice stiff peak
add in strawberry puree with gelatin one
scoop at a time so
it doesn't defray the whipped cream you
just created
and you can mix it evenly so
for eugene i'm adding more alcohol
one tablespoon this looks good and
smells good
put this in a piping bag and if you are
cooking by yourself
sometimes it's difficult to hold piping
back because it's very
soft so tall glass coming
handy so far i'm making a lot of
different components to impress eugene
so i hope he likes it i have popped her
infused
strawberry mousse with rum copter
strawberry
jelly and poptart cake crushed with rum
pipe mousse in the mold and i have
another
silicon sphere mold add this chile
so if you don't have this kind of mold
you can use
ramekin or muffin tin but this silicone
is very handy because it's easy to
unmold use offset spatula
i'm scraping the excess and
creating a flat surface use the
cookie cutter it's exactly same size as
the
mold diameter i brushed round this side
so i'm putting cake
from side down to kind of glue together
it's a little bit
moist freeze this at least three hours
preferably overnight until frozen solid
you might think i'm done but there is
still plenty things to make
15 sheets of gelatin cut in half
and soak in the cold water in the
meanwhile i'm heating up
one and a quarter cup of water and one
and a half cup of sugar using
14 ounce of condensed milk bring this
to a boil and reduce it to low simmer
all right so it came to a boil
so i'm going to turn this off it's like
a
jellyfish really have you ever seen a
jellyfish in your life oh yeah all the
time
jellyfish is everywhere the gelatin is
dissolved
pour this over the mesh sieve
so if there is any gelatine bits won't
be
get into this mixture and start whisk
it's a good thing we are using gloss
ball i can see
all the white chocolate melted i want to
divide my white chocolate mixture
one for one third the other for two
thirds
the fewer amount one i'm going to add
white
food coloring just want to make it
like pure white the other container i'm
going to add
red color i feel like using
like bright red so right now the mixture
is pretty hot
and i have to weigh these ridges to 90
to 95 degrees
and once it's ready i'm going to move on
to next step
i have frozen pop-tarts mousse cake
a mold just push look at that
so cute as my shirt says anything
round is cute it's very important this
cake
is frozen i'm going to use container
with spa
pour like one inch
and pour red same amount
swell once and
pour so pretty i think maybe this is the
fanciest thing i've ever made
look at that it's nice it's like moving
it's almost look like a jellyfish
it's so beautiful and i'm still not done
i'm gonna make some topping
i have some little cookie cutter and cut
up
some pop tart and i have strawberries
i'm gonna cut in half
and i have some left over i'm adding pop
tart dust
around the edge it's like jellyfish in a
beach they have some suns all the cakes
are coated with pop tarts dust
i'm going to little flower
star strawberry
so pretty and we are done
[Music]
pop tarts mira grate strawberry cake now
it's
time to see what eugene thinks
hi eugene hello thank you so much for
joining make it fancy thank you for
inviting me
i love everything you do and i'm really
excited to see what you've done with
this pop-tart especially if you put in a
little something
something special yeah i promised that
we delivered you
some package can you open that i feel
like you're kid at school
if your kid was allowed to drink
wow oh my god that was not what i was
expecting at all
that is beautiful rie thank you
can you guess how i made
pop tarts into this cake i'm guessing
you went with a
strawberry or raspberry filling
inspiration
yes knowing that pop-tart is a
pastry a bad pastry but it's a pastry
you probably went with something flaky
or cakey right
making more cakey okay let's find out
and dig in three two
one oh wow
i made pop tart strawberry mousse cake
strawberry mousse cake so the bottom
layer is cake you have
strawberry mousse and uh jelly filling
yes let me let me take a taste cheers
yes that is so good
you know a lot of viewers they watch
cooking videos and shows they don't get
to taste it but
they can know for me you are an amazing
chef that is so tasty rum
ah okay that makes sense with the fruit
flavor so
did i made pop tarts fancy read
you only not made it fancy you made it
fantastic
one thing we have left to do three
two one make it fancy
and drunk
[Music]
you